welcome back an illegal immigrant
allegedly assaults a female border
patrol agent in Tucson Arizona she was
taken to the hospital after suffering
injuries to her face and hands the
suspect is in custody this vicious
attack highlighting the toll President
Biden's open borders is having on these
sworns but those he sworn to protect
with a nine percent increase this year
and almost 75 percent increase since
2020. joining us right now former border
security section chief Lacey Cooper uh
Chief first off your reaction to this
incident
well it's absolutely tragic what
happened to our female border patrol
agent but let's not pretend that this is
not is an unusual occurrence our border
patrol agents are putting themselves In
Harm's Way every single day that they go
out there and try to protect our
Southern border from the flow of folks
coming across many of whom are are not a
you know immediate threat to a physical
safety but a lot of those folks who are
crossing have criminal convictions many
violent criminal convictions and
obviously as we see here when do you
have somebody who has a propensity for
violence and a border patrol agent goes
Hands-On don't be surprised when that
agent gets hurt so a lot of the you say
you worked in Yuma before and a lot of
times you know they they surrender but
other times you know border patrol
agents today got to be social workers
herein lies the problem
yeah absolutely I was uh the supervisor
over the Yuma sector and this happened
in Tucson sector let me just kind of
tell you the difference in Yuma sector a
lot of Migrant families are coming
across and unaccompanied minors and
those folks typically are
self-surrendering to border patrol and
border patrol agents then you know give
them a shower and some food and maybe
some clean clothes in Tucson sector it's
not like that we have a lot of single
adult males who cross in Tucson sector
because of the wide swaths of land that
are open there and those folks are told
by the cartels if you try if a border
patrol agent tries to apprehend you you
run and you fight
so now the administration is putting
together some policies very similar to
the Trump Administration the first place
you step into that's the place that you
have to apply for citizenship you fill
out the app and if they like you and you
pass the test they'll fly you across the
border and they say because of that
numbers are down is that really an
accurate betrayal of what's happening
with illegal immigration
well have we seen numbers actually go
down I haven't seen that happen yet but
let's uh let's be clear that that policy
that the Trump Administration put in
place is it arises out of federal law it
was just an enforcement of the law that
was already on the books and the Biden
Administration decided not to enforce it
and guess what happened we had two
million migrant Crossings over the last
couple of years each year and we have
1.2 million known godaways so is this
implementation of a law that's already
gonna on the books going to fix our
border crisis it's going to help but
only if the exceptions don't swallow the
rule I looked through the policy and the
in the intentions there and there are so
many loopholes in the policy that if
everybody gets in without any
enforcement of requiring them to to
apply in a safe Third Country we're not
going to have any uh positive outcome at
the border absolutely first off number
one you have to try to control the
border and number two then you have to
implement the right policies I like to
see them do both um call me crazy Lacey
Cooper thanks so much